Rampage Jackson he talked about it on on
your show that he was going to his one
fight that he wants to come back with is
the guy Daryl shover and I didn't like
it I want to be very clear I told him
and my boy Harrison who owns U UFL I
said titties he he hasn't fought darl
skover we got to quit call them titties
man that's I know darl Quinton was like
oh I'm gonna come back and fight I'd
love to fight titties a don't call them
titties B titties like I he's like a
construction guy he hasn't worked fight
in like eight years now for those of you
that don't know no darl skover no he was
on my team uh coached by Rashad Evans on
The Ultimate Fighter season 10 Rampage
and darl skover hated each other Rampage
gave him the nickname titties which some
would say is a form of bullying and they
they got to it they're supposed to fight
on the show like they they were GNA
fight backstage they did not like each
other and Rampages didn't letting this
go